I have this a lot of police of about
four times in the last sixty days a
total of five times I've been probably
more than than 20 times it's more times
than I care to remember
but what you do know is how a very
familiar feeling columns each time I'm
stopped when I see a police officer
behind me and the flashes go off or
they're just driving behind me I'm
nervous I'm conscious of my speed limit
it's always nerve-racking for me I
stopped the car everything to pull it
over the driver looks more like one of
our suspects because the wife said no
you never know what's gonna be the
outcome of traffic stop if you're a
black man
[Music]
so I go through my procedures I try to
stay as calm as possible
like turn on my lights you don't get out
of the car I make sure that my seatbelt
is on right away
windows down so he can immediately see
they're in the weapon my hands need to
be visible
I don't immediately reach for the
glovebox 10 into they'll have my hands
on the steering wheel I speak to them in
a respectful manner record the badge
number in my head have the officer feel
safe because they're on edge you're on
edge and if somebody says or does the
wrong thing this could turn into
something absolutely crazy in 60 seconds
when I was being searched and humiliated
by the deputy including the private
areas my wife Erin was witnessing all
this there's an emotional psychological
impact to constantly being stopped and
profiled by the police department when I
haven't committed any any crimes I
respect police officers I know they have
a tough job I have no respect for bad
cops I'm a big supporter of the police
department but what I'm not a big fan of
is those who take it in their own hands
and are abusing their authority and
abusing their power and claiming fear
police officers are human just like any
other human beings they can make
mistakes and have biases that could
affect their job and their job
performance typically in those
encounters they are the only one who was
armed so what are they afraid of
[Music]